this is a production of Cornell
University so thank you for that nice
introduction Atlanta and thank you and
even for inviting me and thank you all
for talking with me today I've had a
great time talking with faculty and I'm
looking forward to talking to students
soon so as Elena says my study iron
homeostasis in plants and the reason why
I study it is because I under p2c
induced anemia is the most prevalent
nutritional disorder in the world
approximately 30 percent of a global
population suffers from anemia due to
iron deficiency and most people obtain
their iron from plants due to
socio-economic and religious reasons and
so plants can suffer from iron
deficiency but what we want to try to do
is figure out why they sell for how they
suffer and how can we manipulate those
responses to produce plants that contain
more iron or tolerate low iron
conditions and so in response to iron
deficiency they in Diego intervene or
chlorosis and in my favorite plant
rabbit obsessed Aliannah you can see in
addition to that dramatic changes in
root growth and development as well iron
is in and it's doing this because it is
essential for many processes including
both photosynthesis and respiration
where iron is involved in in complexes
and iron super complexes for for these
processes and so in response to iron
deficiency plants depending upon what
type of play we're talking about they
can and you go to different mechanism
strategy one response in a strategy to
response
dicots like a rabid abscess will undergo
the strategy one response in deficiency
so the first thing they do is that they
pump protons into the rhizosphere using
this AHA - or related proteins on this
then lowers the pH and then making a net
mix on become more soluble so ferric
iron is actually the it actually is the
most prevalent is the fourth most
prevalent
a mineral in the Earth's crust and so
plants have to figure out a way to to
solubilize it very good and then reduce
very gyein to ferrous iron right so no
rabbit Oxus then this ferrous iron it is
is then transported into the epidermal
cells by the membrane localized
transporter IRT one and then it travels
from the epidermis into the best feature
eliminates moves from
I shooted Asylum one thing that we don't
really recognize Allah or that we that
we're just now starting to understand is
what's happening inside of specific cell
types for example we know that they are
our aid updates that are prevalent there
are prevalent insight in specific cell
types for example we know that fruit 3
is involved in reducing iron in the
mitochondria the Koshien amine is
involved in producing a type of molecule
called eco she an amine that will bind
to iron in the floor so we'll say this
movement as if one for example is
another important protein involved in
facilitating the movement of the cushion
so there's a lot that's going on not
only at the epidermis but also in more
internal cell types so when I started
working on this project when I was a
postdoc we knew for example that fit was
a key ba Chile's transcription factor
that controlled activity of those three
genes that I told you about at the very
beginning so AHA - ro - ir t1 are all
controlled by FID and so what I was
interested in is trying to figure out
what's what are some of the other key
players in regulating the iron
deficiency response so to try to address
this question and we did a lot of
microarray analysis so micro analysis
was the hot thing to do back when I was
opposed to act now it's hard AC in
proteomics and but this is the this is
the tool that we use in the lab and so
we developed a time course of the iron
deficiency response we're looking at
whole roots between 0 and 72 hours of
exposure time deficiency and then we saw
that it was a major shift happening at
the 24 hour time point so then we slice
the root up into specific developmental
zones and then check the mid microarray
analysis and then we looked at specific
cell types so we use fluorescence
activated that yeah so we use
fluorescence activated cell sorting
which allowed us to isolate specific
cell types that had been exposed to iron
deficient conditions so that what we
could come up with is one is the highest
resolution transcriptional profile of a
plant root in response to iron
deficiency stress and from that my next
goal was to identify putative
transcription factors and use the
reverse genetics approach to try to
figure out do they play a key role in
mistress
and from that approach we identified two
genes which I'll which is kind of from
the basis of my lab to this day one of
them we identified and we named Popeye
so Papa mutants showed decrease on
reductase activity and decreased ability
to acidify the rhizosphere so this is
called a bromo Chris all purple sa so
basically as I said before roots will
protons into the rhizosphere and we can
image that the pumping of the protons
that change in pH on this pH indicator
media alright so in contrast a wild-type
I hope we can see it
Popeye maybe show decreased surprises
for your certification when we go a
papaya mutant on th526 that's pretty
good but when we grow it on elevated pH
in which iron is for these fully
biologically available we see that the
plants will germinate but they won't
work for beyond donation so this is
another example of the iron deficiency
response decreased tolerance the iron
deficiency
however surprisingly I pop on mutants
Ellen
Exhibit D create an increasing the
amount of iron both in the root end in
the chute so this suggests that there is
a disconnect between the actual ability
to uptake iron and the ability to sense
and utilize it so Popeye is playing some
sort of role in disrupting the ability
to sense an ability to utilize iron so
to try to gain insight into how it might
be doing it in the molecular mechanisms
of how Popeye functions well recently
we've looked at the looked at the
dynamics at Popeye's activity so I'm a
very talented student a graduate student
DeRusha wire mohamed teamed up with ross
suits ani to look at the dynamics so we
know that pop I will make a
transcriptional fusion it's expressed
predominantly in the vasculature you're
pretty much seen in vasculature that's
it when we look at a translational
fusion where we can look at the protein
we can actually see that the protein
seems to be localized in all cell types
alright so this suggests that the
protein moves from the best future to
all of the cell types so we teamed up
with rod sassani to do scanning
fluorescence correlation spectroscopy
coupled with pair coalition function so
basically this is a technique in which
we can take high resolution confocal
images
all right and then we can correlate the
signal that fluorescence intensity
across both time and space this provides
you with a carpet that allows you to see
if the protein is moving in between
cells so as is the case for this freely
diffusive GFP or not moving in between
cells as is the case for another mobile
protein that we call t mo v so as we can
see that Popeye is similar to free GFP
moves in between the cell types and
specifically it moves indeed from the
past future to the epidermis so knowing
that now the protein actually moves we
were interested in trying to figure out
what that movement meant for the
activity of Poppa so she cloned the
Popeye protein in front of vascular
specific or behinds a specific promoter
and any normal specific promoter and an
epidermal specific promoter and then we
identified lines and mister protein
stayed in those individual cell types
and then we also identified lines in
which the protein moved from say for
example the vasculature to the
endodermis or from the vasculature to
the cortex or from the epidermis to the
cortex and so then we wanted to see if
we actually express these proteins ones
especially proteins in a papaya mutant
background pretty compliment to function
and so so I'll walk you through this
really quickly so here is wall type
plants showing the and this is under on
deficient conditions so in the classic
risers for your certification all right
here's our papaya mutant show decrease
during a decrease rhizosphere
certification and poor growth under iron
deficient media and we can complement
those functions with the fully under its
native promoter but when we actually
look at some of the lines in which
proper moves from the vasculature to the
endodermis or stays in the vasculature
or stains in in the dermis the the
actual Popeye will continue to grow
poorly under however when we express it
we look at the lines in which papaya
either stays in the cortex and in the
dermis or is or stays in the epidermis
and roots of the cortex common thing
here is that the plants grow better
prepare to use so
suggests us that two things the growth
or a localization of Popeye within the
basket sir or any internal cells it's
harmful to the plant
whereas when we have it in the cortex
and the epidermis particularly the
epidermis the plant seems to grow better
so localization in the cortex is
essential for the function of the
protein hmm so to try to gain insight to
that we did this very well this looks
like a very complicated Venn diagram
after we did my RAC analysis of some of
our lines so we specifically were
interested in ones where prop I moved
from their baskets in the endodermis
from the cortex and amatuer vasculature
to the epidermis into the cortex we're
interested in trying to figure out what
is the transcriptional profile is it
different between the different lines
and we were actually able to identify a
significant number of genes that
exhibited a state change movie went from
off to on on off in lines for example in
which the protein move from vasculature
to the integers so this provides us with
a really exciting set of candidates that
might explain how Popeye does what it
does in specific cells how it's actually
able to do two different things
depending upon whether you have it in
the vasculature and endodermis or
whatever you have it in the cortex and
so that work is in preparation we're
writing that up now and hopefully we'll
get some reviews see so so that's well
that's the story that we're working on
in terms of Popeyes dynamics but study
that may lead you to the question of
okay it's moving between serotypes or
what is it to it so it's a beach at
least transcription factor based upon
homology so one of the first things we
did was look to see what are some of
this potential direct and indirect
targets using microarray analysis and we
see that many genes involved in iron
homeostasis as well as other precedents
for suzy's or just regulated Popeye
mutant background and what I want to
point out here is that zip through and
that some of the three three of the
genes that I pointed out at the very
beginning of the talk I actually
upregulated in a Popeye mutant
background so just pressing their
expression we then did ship shipped to C
which is another old-school okay it's an
oldest technique that we that allows us
to identify the right now.we
least one hybrid analysis and other
various techniques but chip-chip allowed
us to identify the RIC targets and we
found that Papa seems to be directly
regulating genes involved in not only
iron homeostasis but a variety of other
processes including these three targets
right here so these three targets so
many known either my sister's genes are
upregulated and some of them are
directly targeted by pop so knowing that
Popeye's a transcription factor is a pH
LH protein we also know that most
beautiful teens for heterodimers it will
interact with other EH&S proteins that
will help control its activity as a
transcription factor so we conducted a
directed yeast two-hybrid analysis
looking at Popeye homologues that were
closely that that had close homology to
pop so here you can see that the group
for they papa falls within the group B
category but then it actually interacts
with almost all the proteins you can't
really see 104 but it interacts with
luminol Falls also but it interacts with
several of the group for cbhe lish
proteins including IL r 3 alright so I
let three shown here so we did biopsy
analysis to confirm that Popeye and il R
3 interact and they interact
specifically in the nucleus and we also
confirmed that Popeye interacts with
some of the other homologues that we
identified in our yeast two-hybrid
analysis so Popeye's transcription
factor arose many things I mean it
interacts with Apapa homolog in the
nucleus so that leads to the question of
what is il R 3 doing so il R 3 is a
similar to Poppa as expressed so here is
a ghost's transcriptional fusion of il R
3 and a plus and minus sign is expressed
specifically in the best feature but we
look at the protein it seems to be
localized in all cell types so similar
to Papa il R 3 is looks like it's a
mobile protein moves in a basket or to
all other cell types
what's the phenotype
and efficiency so iíll are three mutants
showed decreased elements to iron
deficiency increase chlorosis and we
make a papaya three double mutant we see
a similar phenotype so the they do not
seem to be the mutants don't seem to be
synergistic suggesting that they're part
of the same pathway we look at the
expression of ILR 3 and a pop I'm eating
background it seems to be elevated
suggesting that Papa might be upstream
of ILR 3 in facilitating its repression
however when we look at Co expression
analysis we see that Popeyes
co-expressed with many of them well
known on homeostasis genes including fro
3 pH 101 yeah it's 101 on ask for is if
when these are all well-known iron
homeostasis you pop is called regulating
you but I Allah 3 is not co regulated
with this suggested that maybe aisle are
3 although it plays a role in ion
homeostasis it plays a role in something
else as well I mean so what is that's
something else well siobhan Grady and
Daniel even Stein had been doing a
really extensive yeast one high base
cream of still specific transcription
factors and they found that aisle are
three by instead of promoter of many
genes involved in Lucas enolate
synthesis right so over over half that a
transcription factors involved in the
synthesis of enzymes involved in good
sleep so this is are bound to a
controlled by il R 3 so we picked
several of the enzymes that were that
seem to be missing press both in Popeye
as well as il R 3 and check the
expression in the background of the
single mutants and the double mutants
and we indeed found that
Popeye seems to have the opposite effect
on the expression of these genes
compared to il R 3 so for example mam
one which is a key enzyme involved in
the first step in google assimilate
services and a pup I'm eating in a
Popeye mutant background if the
expression goes down compared to wall
fight but expression goes up and I allow
3b suggesting that Papa might be
involved in the activation of Man 1
whereas Isla 3 is involved in repression
of Man 1 so 2 seem to have opposing
roles so then we teamed up with Daniel
Cleveland Stein who is the Google
guru and we measure google simulate
responses and the results were not as
clear but I wanted to I wanted to see
quickly up and down for a lot Korean
Papa what we did find is that there were
effects we thought that ila 3 did seem
to grow up in both in the roots in both
defund it we found a Google silly did
seem to Gloria pandan Isle a three
mutant background in both a double use
as well as the individual movies
particularly in the group and we didn't
see his dramatic effect on a Papa mutant
background we also saw that these
effects were somewhat iron-deficiency
dependent so this suggests that ILR 3
and papa act to act in an opposing way
to modulate the synthesis of gooks and
leads under iron-deficiency to see this
had any biological and physiological
relevance at all we teamed up with Eric
Davis who is a plant pathologist who
works on soybeans and so in which also
effects of Robert OPS's plants so we
check the expression of I allow 3 with
our Gus lines in under plus and minus
iron at the same age places what we
normally used to look at measurements
look at sis infections and then we
infected both irons sufficient and iron
deficient plants or plants that have
been grown under these conditions to the
cyst nematode and we were able to see
that under iron sufficiency even we can
see an increase in the activity or an
expression of dialogue so this suggests
that somehow the system fiction induces
the expression of these of this gene so
then we measure Lee quantify the actual
infection of the cyst nematode of plants
that were exposed to both plus and minus
iron in both Papa mutant Isle are three
mutant and a double mutant background
and we found that indeed there was a
decrease in the antenna in the ILR 3 and
a double mutant background suggesting
that the increase in the amount of
glucosinolates
contributes to the decreased infection
of cyst nematode and we pick cyst
nematode because they're wounding
pathogens that because are wounding
pathogens and glucosinolates are induced
in response to feel like i'm going
fast and go fast store down with it you
guys start at 12:20 right okay I'm used
to 12:30 in like 10 minutes
all right so so yes Popeye and I eloped
we seem to play this opposing role
potentially a new facility synthesis
perhaps in response to iron deficiency
and so the model that I published is
that Popeye controls ILR 3 and in Iowa 3
plays this role in both iron homeostasis
and in glucosinolates whereas Popeye is
controlling other things in addition to
ILR 3 that plays an overall role in
higher on your faces so and it's kind of
illustrated here so at this point we
were able to add Popeye to this
regulatory network we knew that Popeyes
seems to be directly repressing genes
that play an own role in iron
homeostasis now we can add to this to
this network also that Popeye directly
interacts with several homologs
including ILR 3 and we can also keep in
mind that Papa has a mobile protein that
plays a role in controlling iron ore
meiosis even though it's even though it
seems to disconnect the ability to sense
and utilize a tire that's inside a plant
and we add on
we layer onto the suspect that Popeye
seems to be repressing ILR 3 which plays
a role in replacing glucosinolate
synthesis so somehow this interplay
modulates efficiency so i've spent the
majority of this time talking about the
first thing but the second thing that we
identified during this initial screen
was a gene that we named brutus because
in contrast to Popeye Brutus mutants
grow better than wild-type under iron
deficient and Isha's so now we have
Brutus versus Popeye so in addition as
and as you can see here when you look at
Brice's for your certification we see a
dramatic increase in abilities to
acidify the rhizosphere which can help
to explain why the plants score better
and iron deficient so my graduate
student Rosalyn Samira made a Brutus
promoter Gus transcriptional Gus fusion
and we can see that indeed the the gene
seems to be induced in response to iron
deficiency when we look at the shoes
however it seems to be in our hands
consistently expressed look at floral
tissues and reproductive tissues we see
it as constitutive we see that it
specifically expressed and we also see
that the expression seems to fade out
over time as the leaves reach senescence
we were really intrigued by this
expression pattern and it suggested that
Buddha's might play some potential role
and loading iron into the seed and this
was particularly interesting because we
also know that they were embryo lethal
alleles of brutus all right so here are
some of our brutus alleles that we've
identified but some of the embryo lethal
alleles
suggested that perhaps this role you
know brutus
it is substantiative idea the critics
playing some sort of role in loading
iron into the sea during development so
these are lilz so arrests at two
different stages of embryo develop and
so we went back to all these alleles and
we looked at embryo lethality and we can
see that brutus Lil's
do show an increase in the REO lethality
and we measure the amount of iron that
was associated
the seeds and we can see that both iron
and zinc are elevated in these Brutus
mutants and we can actually visualize
this when we stain using pearl staining
so this suggests that loss of Brutus
function leads to an increase in the
amount of iron in the seeds and then
this leads to our then this leads to
Arrested Development during
embryogenesis
so suggest that brutus represses iron
uptake make sure that we don't have too
much time that's transported into the
developing seed so house we're disabled
to do this what type of protein is Rinku
as I said initially we were looking for
transcription factors in our initial
screen and I pulled this out because it
had a seat why zinc thing your DNA
potential DNA binding go I was really
excited about this and I presented at
that meeting I was a Jose it was like
why are you focusing on this we used to
be focusing on this and this so so so I
started looking more at these are
they're interesting domains and one is
III domain so III ligases actually
facilitate the nation of target proteins
so it pairs up with e 1 e 2 and in this
III will actually cause ubiquitin
molecules to be transferred from d2 to
the substrate and once it's tagged with
multiple ubiquitin change it's targeted
for degradation by the 26s protease so
then we tried in order to figure out
what Brutus might be facilitating base
you know we conducted yeast one a
non-biased yeast to yeast two-hybrid
screen so we pulled out we made a cDNA
library of the root and we tried to
identify things that Brutus might be
using this yeast screen and so we found
a Brutus interacted with several
proteins two of which for the same
family of proteins that pop I physically
interact so now I had a story where you
have Brutus and Popeye they actually
might be doing something together they
may be playing a role together in this
whole in this whole story mmm so so then
we went back and we checks to see if
Brutus and Popeye interact they do not
interact
however Popeye
however Brutus does interact with Popeye
homologs so we went back and we did buy
a biopsy and we saw the Brutus in a
record for example with a lr3
the Brutus is not interact with Popeye
so this is just showing you biopsy in
Oceania samples in which which were
expressing our FB fused to a nuclear tag
so if you see green signal appeared with
the red signal you know that's
interacting at the nucleus and so we
also confirm this with
co-immunoprecipitation mm-hmm however
when you remove the e3 domain you lose
the interaction between Brutus and IO r3
you can see that here as well as on our
Co IP this suggested Brutus's
interaction with the pup I like proteins
requires the e3 domain so now the next
step was to show that Brutus is actually
indeed enzymatic lady 3 ligase so for
this we use them Beecher ubiquitination
and the person who did this and I'm
sorry I don't have his picture here very
talented postdoc de vache still ok he
was actually a postdoc and Elena's lab
so I managed to you know I was grateful
that I was able to recruit them because
that was fantastic
so Brutus is a really tough protein to
work with so anything any data that he
brought in that was really - Brutus I
was always excited about because no one
else could had his hands to work with it
so basically what this is an is an in
vitro ubiquity assing and what I want
you to notice is that when you had you
know you had to eat one and you etude
Brutus you're looking for the formation
of
ubiquitin ubiquitin tags right you can
actually see that when am I getting
ahead of my house a little bit getting a
little bit ahead of myself yeah right
what I want you to focus on is that you
can actually see the formation of these
ubiquitous here suggesting that it is
and
and I'll explain the rest of this in a
few slides for now so we saw that it
actually seems to actually form these
ubiquitin chains and when we remove the
III domain you see a loss of the
formation of these poly ubiquitinated
jesting that it is an e3 ligase so when
we do cell-free degradation assays we
can see that you can actually see the
accumulation aisle r3 in a previous
meeting background but not in wild-type
alright and this all seemed to be relied
upon the degradation of IL r3 oops and
we can also see this in vivo when we
look at the presence of IL are three
translation futures in a brief speeding
background so now we have evidence that
Bruce is indeed in III lyday's what
about these other domains so these are
human reasoning domains in mammalian
cells had been shown to bind iron in
these by an iron in these oxygen pockets
so we had a potential iron binding motif
to try to figure out if Brutus indeed
directly bonds iron you purify the
protein we made a multiple binding
protein his tag variation of brutus and
then we made another version when we
remove the him every three domains and
you can see that they expect we see a
dramatic decrease in the amount of iron
and zinc associated with the Hemi recent
domains suggesting that Brutus does
facilitate interaction with iron ore
that Brutus bronze iron okay so the but
the really cool thing is that when we in
vitro transcribed and translated the
protein in their presence of increasing
amounts of soluble iron we see that the
protein goes away suggesting that it's
destabilized in the presence of
increasing amounts of iron when we
removed the him urethra in domain we
moved this entire trunk we see that the
protein remains stable in increasing
amounts of cyber line this suggests that
the binding of iron facilitates the
degradation of
and we were also gratified to see they
win that we're also gratified to see
that when we look at our Brutus a Murray
Thunder main we can see the protein is
much more stabilized much more prevalent
than the version which then the
full-length protein right and it's much
more prevalent than when you remove the
e3 domain so the Hemi wreathen domain is
not only responsible for binding on it's
responsible for the stabilization of the
protein so now go back to this image and
you can see in the presence of e1 and e2
when you remove the him everything to me
you see a much more dramatic increase in
the amount of mana rebuking to change
this suggests that the stabilized
version of the protein is really
strongly in III ligase and likewise when
you remove the him Aretha in domain in
Ex very much like wall type in that il
r3 is no longer present so now we can
add to this model the idea that Brutus
is interacting with these about
homologues and facilitating their
degradation and what I think this might
be doing is in the absence of iron you
see an increase in the amount of brutus
that's transcriptionally induced to the
protein accumulating and then once the
plant gets sufficient amounts of iron
balusters brutus and it's rapidly
facilitating the segregation allowing
the tight control of iron homeostasis
responses in response to changes in iron
I don't know the rest of the field buys
it but that's my current model for right
now once it okay great so
another thing that I wanted to point out
with respect to Bruce is that these are
not the only things that Brutus seems to
interact with in that yeast two-hybrid
analysis they also interact with another
another transcription factor which is
not a BH in this transcription factor
and then gene called important alpha
which encodes a protein that may be
involved in localization so we're really
intrigued by this interaction as well
and we were interested in Boz - because
vastu plays a role in abiotic stress
response such as drought stress as well
as response to pathogens and studies
that shown that it was degraded in an mg
one thing it was like a no-brainer as
that oh it must be interacting with
Brutus and was facilitating his
degradation all right so we wanted to
follow up on that so we went back to our
biopsy analysis and we showed that
indeed
Brutus seems to act with Boz - in the
nucleus in a cytosol it also interacts
with an important in the nucleus when
you remove the e3 domain we lose the
interaction with vos - but we don't lose
the interaction with so this is just
that Brutus interacts with proteins like
specifically with transcription factors
and maybe a facility segregation but
when it interacts with something that's
not a transcription factor like this
important protein
it doesn't facilitate its degradation it
doesn't iraq but maybe the important
protein is facilitating its movement
into the nucleus nose and so to verify
this we went back to our selfie
degradation assay the first thing that
I'll point out is that no matter what
you do with important it's always there
but when you have your when you look at
bars - you see that it's degraded in the
presence in an empty 1:32 dependent
manner
Brutus mutant not degraded when we look
at our
Brutus mutant which has the full leaf
protein or Abril Brutus mutant where you
have a protein with the Hemi riether
domain removed you don't see the protein
so the protein is facility is degraded
but it's not a graded when you remove
the e3 domain again showing that Brutus
is facilitating the degradation of vaz -
in a way that it was doing with the
protein
but it's not facilitating the great the
degradation of importance so we wanted
to see what's the biological relevance
maybe Brutus is doing something outside
of iron homeostasis so we went back and
we teamed of Oz to antibody from
colleagues in Yash I was a Japanese
group and he Athena being our co-author
in the paper and what we found is that
in increasing amounts of drought stress
of cold stress boss to expression of Oz
to protein goes down but when we look at
the Brutus with the deity give Pete a
Brutus we see that the protein
accumulates so in the presence of
increasing amounts of Brutus
there's decreasing amounts of Oz to
further correlation that this
interaction between two least of Oz is
degradation the final thing we did was
check the drought stress response and
Sona Baz to mutant cities it shown that
compared to wild-type there were more
tolerant to drought sprout stress so we
suspected that avaaz to mutant would be
very similar to the overexpression of
brutus in terms of drought response and
indeed we saw the we overexpress Brutus
we see an increase in drought tolerance
very similar to what happens when we
look at the loss of function units for
of Oz one advice - all right so that's
it so that's suggesting that maybe
Brutus is doing something in terms of
drought response through its interaction
with boss so now we have another layer
to this regulatory network and in
between this time that we've been
working on this a whole lot of other
labs have become interested in the story
and have added new players stories
getting more and more complex whole
other set of transcription factors came
that were involved in this response so
it's a really exciting time to be
working in this in this field and so in
the last few minutes I'll finish up with
a story that we've been developing
that's working with engineers making
using / modeling approach and a
thematical approach to gain insights and
slow process so we went back to our time
course analysis and I approached
Williams and is a very talented graduate
student I'm to try to see if we could
utilize this data to try to identify new
plays and so the overarching question
that we were interested in asking is if
there are some known iron homeostasis
teens that are induced repressed within
24 48 or 72 hours can we identify things
that are upstream of it based upon the
expression pattern of some of these
genes that are occurring earlier on in
the process and so there many different
ways that we can do this and this is
just a picture that from a review that
describes some of the different
algorithms or approaches that you can
take to try to identify relationships
between genes down here with genes
appear and so one of the things that you
can do is you input the iron deficiency
response genes you cluster them and then
you make identify relationships based
upon expression so that was our first
our first aim in doing this project and
so we developed an algorithm to try to
address this question so we call this
the CDA a algorithm the cluster and
differentiation alignment algorithm and
so we picked a set of well known iron
homeostasis genes and we use this
algorithm and identified a number of
genes that may be regulating them that
had no no and I know miss thesis
response and so then we order the
mutants for all of these and then check
the expression of their putative targets
using three forward qrt-pcr analysis so
then we also had a control and so we
found is that in over 60% of the cases
we were able to recapitulate that these
genes affected the expression of B's
genes right however we were not often
able to predict the directionality of
their expression so for example we
predicted that ETF 9 would activate the
expression of a lot of these genes and
it turns out and actually represses
right so to further validate this
network we sent because we had the
promoter for papa we said that
for papaya Siobhan Brady to do her yeast
upon hybrid analysis since she was able
to indeed on that acyl to bonds are so
decided some biological validation to
our network so what we've been more
recently interested in is moving beyond
the static relationship to try to
understand dynamics of that relationship
how does modulating the expression of
these genes affect the expression of
these can we developed can we develop
and the equation that explains these
relationships but to do these we
actually had to include the new players
that were being developed between 2015
and 2018 so these key players came up as
being regulating as regulating some of
these known I'm home ec sixties as well
so knowing this new network we decided
to create or to try and a mathematical
approach we created a version of an
ordinary different ordinary differential
equation o de that took into effect
things like the iron deprivation signal
the degradation rate of the transcripts
the idea that some things might be
considerably transcribed other unknown
iron related effects so there were its
princess took us quite a bit of time and
quite a bit of back and forth to try to
create an OD at a variety of different
parameters many of which we didn't know
and so what we ended up with is the
ability to be able to predict what
happens when we look at combinatorial
effects so for example when we look at
the expression of say mid tin which is
which is down here what happens when we
look at the effect of multiple
modulators on its activity all right so
here's nipton this is expression in wall
type plants under iron deficiency
alright and our single mutants the
expression of nipton looks like this in
a 104 mutant background this is one of
its regulators right this is another one
of its regulators and here's the W so
then we can sit we can take the
information about the expression pattern
written in the background of 104 or the
background of IL R 3 and
we can use this mathematical model to
predict what would happen to exist in a
double mute right and so in over 50% and
so in the majority of the cases we were
able to predict what we can it higher or
abused so now with this these new
approaches that we've been taking with
our engineering colleagues we're able to
further enhance this regulatory network
by adding in another layer of regulators
and some and I'm only showing Asil to
here because I know it actually directly
regulates papaya but the network extends
to some of these new players as well and
with that but like the fake all of my
various people that have collaborated
with me in particular masa Sato who was
our collaborator for the past to project
your Davis Daniel even stein I'm also
have a collaboration of course Siobhan I
also have collaborations going on with
John Mead a local hero or you don't
didn't have time to talk about today
create us Williams Joe the cost James
took and of course Ross suits honey and
then a variety of undergraduate graduate
students and postdocs particularly devs
soluti Roslyn Sameera and DeRusha
waoranis Taubman who've been he and
doing some of the talk about and I also
like the King of course the National
Science Foundation and in CSU for small
pockets
[Applause]
you tough city you save a lot of times
the arrows were wrong in the prediction
how many why it's not I think so that
when you look at just based upon
expression patterns you would predict
when something goes up and if the target
goes up and radicular will go up but
sometimes you can have something that
goes up but it's actually having a
repressive effect and so I don't think
we're eight we didn't really take that
into T into account plus we were looking
at the effect of multiple modulators so
we can have something that goes up and
it's we're pressing or nothing that's
goes that goes up and activates and I
think that this is where we and I keep
using this theorem with our graduate
students who I think this is where we're
getting into the area where weird no no
longer looking at low-hanging fruit
we're really trying to figure out what
are all of the names that control the
expression of x y&z whether it's an
activator or a repressor so it makes it
more difficult but it also gives us it
gets a deeper this is deeper into
answering any questions of what controls
gene it's not environment nearly
responsive if you you can see very well
but it seems to be localized and also
types kind of both plus and minus so I
don't think an iron deficiency is making
it I do think that where it's localized
determines what is binding partners are
and then that determines what it's
downstream targets are but in terms of
iron deficiency is just making it
accumulate more it's not changing it's
not causing which would have been cool
are you going to further investigate no
we'd love to further investigate the
thing is you just need more data so we
need to look at kinetics we need to look
more carefully at so so right now we're
trying to create a similar model looking
at
jeans that are looking at a specific
cell types so that model was predicted
was based upon data from whole route
microarray analysis right now we're
trying to focus we're doing the same
thing with an RNA seek on the epidermis
same time course but we're trying to use
that same model we're hoping that we'll
get a cleaner model because we don't
take into effect you know things that
are moving between cells or things that
are you know really not a you know we're
integer and really trying to hone in on
what's happening in their specific cell
and I could diluted it but yeah I'd love
to work with dope deeper into the model
I just need hands and interested
students MacRay gnosis who's lab is
really really keen on finger domain
actually I don't know that's something
that I never attested once I get started
by the ìiî domain and the Huey I was
like yeah but it may very well be acting
as or maybe binding to zinc or maybe
buying it to some other other metal but
that's something that we've we've cloned
those individual domains I just have it
could be the same we didn't take that we
just looked at that's you know and I was
so focused on iron that I didn't eggsy
but that's something that we should we
should check and it could very well be
that it's just as stable and zinc will
be really cool instead it wasn't exactly
that will be exact you did other
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu